it is an achievement of sorts that talks
between russia and the united states and
geneva didn't end in failure they were
never likely to be a major success
but while russia insisted it had no
intention of invading ukraine there
remains little sign of an immediate end
to the crisis it's not a situation where
a deal breaker
one way or another
is envisioned unfortunately we have
a great disparity in our principled
approaches to this u.s and russia
in some ways
have
opposite views on what needs to be done
u.s negotiators trod carefully they
promised there wouldn't be talk of
ukraine's security without ukraine
present this instead a chance to air
respective concerns and get a measure of
russia's true intent
with tensions at their highest since the
end of the cold war points of dispute
between russia and the us are plentiful
but ukraine is perhaps most urgent
russia has supported a separatist
conflict there for eight years now and
the presence of a hundred thousand
russian troops on ukraine's border
threatens a new war in europe
russia wants legal guarantees that
ukraine will never become a member of
the nato alliance a demand flatly
rejected by western allies
on monday ukraine's deputy prime
minister met the nato secretary general
talks with russia will widen on
wednesday to include nato members in
brussels and then the osce in vienna on
thursday
what russia is doing is tries to impose
its agenda instead of returning to the
negotiation table
and we have stated very clearly
that we will never compromise on the
right for every nation in europe to
choose its own path
including what kind of security
arrangements it wants to be a part of
earlier russia's deputy foreign minister
suggested the u.s had not taken
seriously his country's demand that
ukraine never be allowed to join nato
that's an ominous sign by continuing to
press what is a solid western red line
russia may be showing its hand that
president putin may not intend this week
of talks to succeed at all but rather to
use them as a pretext for war
jonah al jazeera
[Applause]